and one of those things is
insulting another Muslim,
insulting. A Muslim is not an
insulting person. A Muslim is
not. A person who is. kind
of mocking of other people and
looking down at other people.
What is insulting? Here Abdul
Kaim Rahim he says one of the
things that the prophet
prohibited that a person say or
is that? A Muslim insult
another Muslim. That a Muslim
insult another Muslim. And what
is meant by an insult? What is
an insult? An insult isn't
necessarily vulgarity. Doesn't
have to involve vulgarity. It
doesn't mean that you are
vulgar in your speech
necessarily Rather insulting
another person is saying
anything to that person that is
meant to be, that is meant to
be demeaning. Anything you say
to another person that is
demeaning or you are intention
is to mean to demean that
person. That is considered an
insult.
[Silence]
The
because its will make the third
person feel left out. It will
make a third person maybe even
think that the discussion is
about him. This is some which
is prohibited.
[Silence]
The
Avon, right? And when she would
see certain features of this
woman, she may go home and
discuss these features with her
husband. She looks this.
She has this kind of. This is
something which is haram. And
it's a type of and also it's
almost telling another
person's secrets, Exposing your
Muslim. Why? Because a woman
wears hijab because what is
under that hijab is a secret.
It's a secret from other
people. Only certain people
have the right to see that. And
so, if a woman describes
another woman to her husband or
anyone else, it would be worse
to someone else that this is
something that the prophet
specifically prohibited.
Allah
the
[Silence]
say Why? Because it articulates
that a person is not, it
articulates a couple of things
which are incorrect. Number
one, that the person doesn't
really need Allah's
forgiveness. Forgive me if you
want to. Another thing, it's as
if he is asking Allah and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is not
extremely merciful and doesn't
have enough mercy to go around.
What does that mean? So, if I
go to ask someone for a loan or
ask someone for money, they
have a finite amount of money,
right? They have a finite
amount of funds. And so, if
they give me this money, it
might harm them. So, I say, you
please, if you can, if you
will, right? This is not the
case with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He gives and gives and
gives and what he has has never
been depleted from the
inception of the creation of
the heavens and the earth.
In **** Man he and
other.
We have the love of
[Silence]
swearing by Allah.
Because too much of this will
articulate the opposite
meaning. It's as if this is not
a really important thing. It's
something we say all the time.
It has no significance, no
unique significance to it.
What I want? And yes Allah
[Silence]
in Medina became the the city
of lights. The lighted city.
And that is the naming of the
Muslims of Medina. Another that
he mentions is that a person
brag about his worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to say I
fasted this much or I prayed
this much And this happens
often. Honestly. a person
may do something for 20 years.
And then say you know for the
past 20 years I've never missed
Every night at this time I do
this and do that. is something
that goes back to a person's
intention. If the point of it
is that they are telling their
son, they're telling someone
who they have an influence on
in order to influence them to
do something similar, then
that's fine. But it's better to
use the prophet as a reference.
Instead of saying, I never did
this, I always did this. Say,
the prophet never did this. The
prophet always did this. Rather
being a braggart, bragging
about yourself, or using words
that could be interpreted as
bragging, Rather, speak about
those who are better than all
of us, right? However, if a
person does say that with the
intention of bragging or
showing off, this is something
that could invalidate there,
invalidate their deeds. So,
this is something that a person
has to take into account and be
very vigilant of. Many Muslims.
Alhamdulillah, they have a good
history. They've done a lot in
their lives And they may have,
you know, put forth a very
positive effort for the
generations to come. But, many
of them, many of us, we fall
into this pitfall. And that is
becoming a braggart with our
own age, with our old age. You
know, I came here at this age
and I did this and all my life,
I did this, and this is my
work, and this is my work, and
this is what I did, and I did,
and I did, and this is
something which not only is
boastful and dismissive of the
listener but it's also
something that is despised by
Allah. That's enough for
tonight.
[Arabic recitation]